bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde nous sommes en direct à douze
jours du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle nous vous proposons
désormais chaque soir un grand débat sur
un thème de campagne ce soir l'hôpital
au bord de la rupture pénurie
d'infirmières d'aides-soignantes mais
aussi de médecins tous les xive et par
la crise sanitaire de diagnostic fait
froid dans le dos alors quelles sont les
propositions des candidats pour sauver
un modèle aujourd'hui en péril on en
parle dans un instant avec nos invités
l'hôpital public notre grand témoin l'a
choisi pour sauver des gens mais aussi
pour l'adrénaline la médecine il la
pratique en seine saint denis
département le plus pauvre de france est
une grande gueule c'est lui joue parfois
des tours surtout quand on a une famille
litres comme lui mathias baron est avec
nous se soit enfin ce sera le scan coupe
projecteurs ce soir sur les petits
candidats dans le carnet de campagne de
stéphane blakowski et puis nous vous
dévoilerons notre baromètre mensuel au
dr céline bracq ce soir passera au
crible la dynamique mélenchon voilà pour
le menu c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs s'il ya une chose que
l'épidémie a changé c'est que la santé
est devenue l'une des principales
d'attentes des français les candidats ne
peuvent plus la reléguer aux dernières
pages de leurs programmes chaque fois
jusqu'au premier tour désormais on va
s'arrêter sur un thème de campagne on
commence ce soir avec l'hôpital que vous
connaissez très bien mathias wargon
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
médecins urgentistes est la tête des
urgences de l'hôpital delafontaine à
saint denis vous publiez avec la
collaboration de jean marie godard
hôpital un chef-d'oeuvre en péril chez
fayard vision sans concession de
l'hôpital public tombée dans la
médiocrité
écrivez vous avez des pistes de solution
on va en parler puis dans la deuxième
partie on parlera un petit peu de vous
parce que dans ce livre vous racontez
aussi votre parcours vos coups de gueule
notamment contre les épidémiologistes de
plateau qui vous agace au plus haut
point on verra cela et vous nous direz
comment vous vivez ce que vous appelez
votre micro célébrités on en parlera de
tout à leur nom commence par l'essentiel
l'état de santé de l'hôpital bonsoir
bertrand guidet mon professeur guy des
merci d'être avec nous chef du service
de médecine intensive réanimation à
l'hôpital saint-antoine membre de
l'académie de médecine bonsoir n'aura
sahara merci d'être là vous avez été
infirmière pendant 15 ans vous avez
choisi de quitter ce métier au moment de
la deuxième vague du coc vide et vous en
avez fait un livre l'année dernière
hôpital si les gens savaient aux
éditions robert laffont c'est le fruit
aussi d'une enquête au cours de laquelle
vous avez rencontré plus d'une centaines
de soignants enfin bonsoir jean de
kervasdoué ravi de vous retrouver sur ce
plateau et économiste de la santé ancien
professeur au cnam et ancien directeur
général des hôpitaux alors on va
commencer par le terrain en images on va
partir au fond de ce qui est symbole de
la crise de l'hôpital des urgences même
si il ya bien d'autres services qui
souffrent à laval zone de désert médical
les médecins urgentistes sont de moins
en moins nombreux reportage signé
clément pernot et marion becker regarder
je vous donne la parole juste après
une nuit aux urgences de l'hôpital de la
balle
les médecins prennent en charge une
femme victime d'un accident de la route
les airbags se sont déclenchés
les urgences ce soir là ne sont ni
complètement ouverte ni totalement
fermer les entrées ils sont régulés elle
a été pris en charge par les pompiers
sur le lieu de l'accident le les
pompiers ont donné le bilan aux médecins
régulateurs et les médecins régulateurs
m'a appelé pour savoir s'il était en
capacité d'accueillir la patiente c'est
un accident on va dire de faibles
cinétique donc il ya moins de risque
vital aurait pu aller à château-gontier
en mayenne la patiente ne doit donc son
admission qu à la faible influence aux
urgences à ce moment là
ses nuits à entrer régulés sont devenues
fréquentes à l'hôpital de laval
la raison l'établissement manque de
médecins urgentistes
il lui faudrait 12 spécialistes
supplémentaires soit les deux tiers de
ses effectifs un cas récurrents dans
l'hôpital public où la gestion des
plannings tient souvent du casse-tête
bonsoir de tamié je peux vous déranger
tannis
et l'est de l'asie est en charge du
recrutement sur le week-end qui
s'annonce pas comment vous avez prévu de
vous organiser du coup parce que je
crois que c'est compliqué en fonction
des intérimaires qu'on peut trouver
peut-être qu'on pourra mettre des
médecins en face mais pour le moment
sans le renfort intérimaire on est
l'incapacité de trouver deux médecins à
l'info aujourd'hui on est aidé par des
maîtres c'est un remplaçant régulier des
intérimaires aussi mais dans une moindre
mesure on cherche des urgentistes on
cherche
des médecins généralistes
on cherche des médecins étrangers
des anciennes internes qui sont passés
chez nous face et on prend madame blazy
comme moi le téléphone pour essayer de
trouver au maximum c'est ça l'urgence
c'est qu'effectivement il faut trouver
des médecins il faut être plus attractif
que les autres c'est un peu là la
bataille des hôpitaux
une bataille pour compenser la crise des
vocations
rémunération jugée trop faible plages
horaires trop contraignantes l'hôpital
n'attire plus
alors les urgences vous connaissez
évidemment mathias wargon vous consacré
de nombreuses pages dans votre livre à
ce métier de combattants c'est comme ça
que vous le décrivez de d'urgentistes à
laval ce sont des urgentistes des
médecins urgentistes qui manquent vous
constatez cela aussi c'est symbolique
partout moi je dans mon service je n'ai
que des médecins étrangers qui sont de
bonne qualité mais il a fallu aller les
chercher à l'étranger donc je n'ai pas
de médecin urgentiste donc un médecin
urgentiste français alors aux urgences
aux urgences même je crois qu'on est
deux plus une dr junior qui vient
d'arriver 3 et les autres sont des
médecins alors ils sont français il y en
a qui sont français qui ont acquis la
nationalité française qu'ils sont
devenus praticien hospitalier
c'est-à-dire médecins des hôpitaux et
qui sont urgentiste mais globalement des
gens qu'on recrute non je recrute
personne et c'est pas l'aval c'est
beaucoup plus près de paris et à part
paris intra muros finalement on a tous
des problèmes de recrutement pourquoi
parce que ce sont c'est un métier très
difficile à la fois à cause des horaires
on l'a dit dans une société quand même
qu'ils glorifient les 35 heures donc
expliquer à des gens qui vont pas avoir
des horaires de bureau qui vont
travailler la nuit et qui vont
travailler très dur la nuit dans un
système en plus l'hôpital qui marchent
pas bien c'est à dire que c'est pas
tellement de recevoir les patients le
problème c'est aussi un problème mais
c'est aussi une fois qu'ils sont dans
notre service faut qu'on leur trouve un
endroit où aller et quand l'hôpital est
plein quand l'hôpital et parfois de
mauvaise volonté eh ben on n'arrive pas
à placer les patients et donc c'est un
enfer il ya des services où ils ont
régulé s'est entraînée par les urgences
c'est à dire que ils ont plus de
problèmes à chercher des lits ils ont
moins de problèmes pour trouver des
médecins on reviendra sur les pièces de
solutions sur les urgences vous faites
des propositions peut-être urgence à
tout prix si j'ose dire n'est pas
forcément la solution bertrand guidet
les urgences c'est le symbole d'une
certaine façon mais vous à saint-antoine
qu'est ce que vous constatez mon manque
de quoi précisément de médecins mais
aussi d'être soignante on amarre les
infirmières donc essentiellement de
fermières et on manque essentiellement
d'infirmières dans les services où le
ratio de personnel par malade est pas
favorable manqué qu'une charge en soins
très élevé
ça touche beaucoup les services de
gériatrie où il ya une prise en charge
qui est extrêmement lourde or la
population française vieillit c'est des
malades qu'on retrouve sur brancard aux
urgences en attente de lits et qui
ajoute de la pression sur les équipes
des urgences
donc le problème il est les médecins
dans certaines spécialités
particulièrement quand il y à une
alternative d'installation privé des
radiologues des chirurgiens des
anesthésistes
et puis parmi le personnel
en tant que vous avez des collègues
médecins qui ont décidé de partir dans
le privé beaucoup oui alors alors
finalement
qui ont vocation pécuniaire mais elles
sont surtout
notre quotidien est vraiment difficile
at il précisé ben c'est pas bien huilé
l'informatique marche pas
je quand je demande quelque chose
l'administration n'est pas n'est pas
réactive voilà et donc il faudrait
pouvoir
finalement faire fructifier nos
modalités de fonctionnement pendant la
crise où effectivement on était entendue
on est elle une telle pression que quand
on demande est effectivement du matériel
supplémentaire et c'est globalement
l'obtenait comme qui avait une fluidité
y avait une réactivité mais aujourd'hui
ce que vous vivez c'est pire qu'elle en
a créés sanitaires ça s'est aggravé ah
oui alors ça dépend des secteurs
ça dépend beaucoup aussi du
fonctionnement des équipes comment elles
ont pu être manager et cetera mais y ait
des équipes énormément souffert avec des
infirmières avec les plans blancs vous
avez on leur a interdit de partir
maintenant le plan blanc se lève et donc
des infirmières qui dont les mutations
étaient bloqués
en parts et donc on se retrouve
effectivement avec vraiment des trous
dans le planning est aussi donc c'est
très franchement nous ouais enfin nous
dans des hôpitaux qui sont pas
universitaire donc je pas très loin de
la paix le personnel est quand même
parti en vacances il ya quand même eu
ses possibilités là ça a été moins dure
finalement volatilisé et du coup mais il
ya quand même une fuite ans c'est pas
que ça enfin on va en parler parce qu'il
ya une plusieurs crises en crises de
reconnaissance crise de de rémunération
et puis crise de sens aussi un et ça
c'est vraiment nouveau on a l'impression
que l'hôpital traverse une crise des
valeurs plus personne ne veut y aller
parce que on prend plus au fond à quoi
ça sert si c'est vraiment utile n'aura
star ce que vous décrivez dans votre
lycée vraiment édifiant vous vous parlez
d'un profond mal-être des infirmières
qui souffrent en silence vous même déjà
expliqué nous qu'est ce qui fait qu'elle
a été la goutte d'eau qui fait qu'après
quinze ans en plein qu'ovide c'est trop
on y retrouve plus moi j'étais
infirmière pendant 15 ans et ça fait
cinquante je suis journaliste et
infirmières donc j'étais la nuit à
l'hôpital et la journée je travaillais
en radio en tant que journaliste santé
et je me suis toujours dit que j'allais
continuer mes deux casquettes parce que
c'est les deux métiers qui me clé c est
en fait la première vague est arrivée et
j'ai vu qu'il y avait voilà un
engouement pour l'hôpital l'intérêt sur
les conditions de travail et de
l'hôpital sachant que moi j'avais
commencé mon enquête en 2019 donc
j'avais vu j'avais eu les échos des
soignants me disant ça va mal ça va mal
et au final on s'est dit super super
entre guillemets il ya une crise donc on
va enfin voir les problèmes qui à
l'hôpital
la première vague est passé moi j'ai été
contaminé pendant la première vague et
j'ai vu que c'était pire en fait les
conditions de travail et puis surtout
qu'il y avait un manque de
reconnaissance des directions pour les
soignants qui vont être contaminés j'ai
été contaminés et
je vous donne un exemple je devais être
en vacances j'ai annulé toutes mes
vacances parce que j'avais ce sentiment
de culpabilité il fallait que j'aide mes
collègues je ne pouvais pas les laisser
ont été en nombre insuffisant et pareil
pour des milliers d'infirmières qui ont
qui ont été dans ce cas là et en fait on
s'est rendu compte que rien ne change et
que les conditions de travail étaient
tout autant déplorables ont pour la
première fois de ma vie j'ai cherché des
sacs poubelles à mettre sur ma tête et
dessus pour aller me protéger on n'avait
pas de masques ffp2 on avait des masques
chirurgicaux et eo2 mazet de la crise
mais même après on a eu que deux masses
pendant toute la période moi j'ai
travaillé jusqu'en jusqu'à le début de
la deuxième vague et on avait des
masques chirurgicaux pour douze heures
de travail et j'ai des collègues qui
continue à travailler et des amis je
suis entouré énormément de soignants et
qui me disent on a jamais vu dff p2 on a
travaillé dans les services on n'a pas
vu des fêtes p2 alors il y avait des
services réanimation et ses acquis 2 mai
dans les services et dans des cliniques
privées on en parle peut aussi y avait
pas d espionner donc pour vous la crise
sanitaire ça a été au fond la goutte
d'eau exactement il vous décrire des
situations où une infirmière pour avoir
jusqu'à 100 patients en une nuit mais ça
ça semble absolument impossible c'est
réel atout
voit les difficultés mais sans passion
patients avec quatre aides soignantes
une aide sur une infirmière oui oui oui
comment comment on peut faire et ben en
fait c'est la roulette russe et on
espère qu'il se passe rien et vous avez
le même la même chose dans des services
de chirurgie où vous avez une infirmière
pour 20 patients avec une aide soignante
avec un peu de chance parfois elle a une
deuxième infirmières elles sont deux
infirmières et c'est pareil cédé 1 des
patients qui sont opérés du jour et sans
médecin sur place il ya un
administrateur de garde qu'on appelle là
je parle pas de l'assistance publique
mais je parle de cliniques privées et
vous devez vous débrouiller alors si
vous avez de la bouteille tant mieux si
vous en avez pas et aussi pas mal de
témoignages sur les traumatismes des
soignants le manque de reconnaissance
alors là on se demande si à vous lire
c'est marginal ou si c'est au contraire
le signal d'alarmé voilà vous et
l'iceberg qui bon vous parlez des burn
out et tentatives de suicides et
d'infirmières qui font des fausses
couches après des nuits de garde ça
c'est quelle ampleur moi j'ai traversé
le pays j'ai traversé pays j'ai
rencontré une centaine d'infirmières y
en a beaucoup qui n'ont pas voulu parler
parce qu'elle avait peur elle avait peur
des directions vous avez peur d'avoir
des répercussions et je me suis rendu
compte qu'il y avait vraiment un mal
être dans le métier et une omerta en
fait elle n'osait pas dire que ça va pas
donc officiellement ça allait elles
tiennent dans les services mais en off
ça va très mal et aujourd'hui encore
j'ai énormément témoignages
d'infirmières qui me disent moi je pars
je sais pas quoi faire parce que j'ai
toujours fait qu'infirmière et je sais
faire que ça mais j'ai envie de partir
donc je suis en train de réfléchir à ma
reconversion et c'est ça qui est encore
plus dramatique c'est que on manque
d'infirmiers aujourd'hui moins soixante
mille infirmières dans le service de
soins elle partait on n'arrive pas à
arrêter on n'arrive pas à recruter et
celles qui sont parties veulent revenir
mais on leur donne pas les moyens de
travailler dignement il revient dit à
quelques rémunérations supplémentaires
ça change rien les 183 euros lieu ses
goûts du secteur de la santé c'est en
fait il ya eu des départs massifs de
soignants et vous avez ces infirmiers
qui sont toujours sur le terrain elles
comblent le vide donc c'est une
surcharge de travail donc c'est
symbolique c'est 183 euros cette
augmentation de 5 jean de kervasdoué
crise des valeurs à l'hôpital
évidemment ça fait des années on en
parle mais là simplement au moins la
question d'hôpital la question de la
santé et dans les priorités et des
français et dans les programmes en
première place emmanuel macron s'il est
élu il a dit éducation santé seront mes
priorités est-ce qu'on est à un tournant
dans la prise de conscience
gelé dire malheureusement enfin may à la
fois un facteur déclenchant et des
causes très ancienne et très profond
mais elles sont multiples et je n'aurais
malheureusement le temps que de les
évoquer alors le facteur déclenchant
c'est un effet paradoxal de quoi qu'il
en coûte me semble-t-il c'est à dire que
les infirmières se sont et les médecins
et les soignants se retrouver seul à
travailler
jour et nuit avoir des difficultés de
transport parce que le transport en
commun marché mal donc il y avait des
problèmes surtout pendant 2020 et ils et
elles ont vu des gens bien qui est il
chez eux à travailler à domicile et
quand même applaudi chaleureusement et
soutenu y avait un moment de
galvanisation malheureuse oui
malheureusement pour la question des
valeurs nous étions un pays de
producteurs enthousiaste le chaume
devenue un pays de consommateurs
inquiets alors ça s'appelle le principe
de précaution ça s'appelle donc ce qui
s'est passé c'est que les gens qui
produisent qui ont besoin d'être là
comme les infirmières comme les
soignants mais c'est vrai aussi des
industriels et des ouvriers on ne trouve
plus la place dans la société il y avait
les chefs d'entreprise qui me disait
l'autre jour que malheureusement pour
toute une série d'inspecteurs qui existe
maintenant les industriels sont devenus
des délinquants et restons sur l'hôpital
mais voilà les révérends dit on paye 30
ans d'incurie c'est fort que cette
phrase
les réformes des 30 dernières années
nous ont menés dans le mur la réponse
est oui alors il y en a eu il y en a il
ya eu beaucoup de cause alors la
première c'est on n'a pas de souplesse
d'organisation l'hôpital et a fait de
très générales c'est que l'état est
rentré dans la gestion hospitalière
guettaf de tout prévoir tout le temps
par des textes la loi de touraine 2016
sédunois faut bien comprendre c'est le
gallois folle c'est à dire que c'est
dans la petite halle c'est
l'administration et elle est annoncée
plein de l'administration
l'administration et les locales et
essaye de faire ce qu'elle peut mais
l'administration locale est très concret
à qui pardonne un certain résultat c'est
moi qui ai rédigé le titre cadres de la
fonction publique hospitalière puisque
cet effet mais ces attributs que la
gauche a payé au parti communiste est un
des problèmes des infirmières c'est que
quand elles sont fonctionnelles elles
rentrent dans une grille et la
possibilité d'avancement c
le temps et ensuite c'est changer de
métier c'est-à-dire quand devient sa
surveillance
voilà mes s'échanger métier alors dont
vous avez un problème d'organisation
vous avez un problème qu'il faut évoquer
c'est la baisse de la démographie des
années 90 il faut dix ans pour former un
médecin donc en 95 à 2000 vous formiez
3500 médecin alors qu'il en fallait plus
doux les gens que vous fermiez ces
années là c'est aujourd'hui les gens qui
ont 40 45 ans et de congères partout et
qu'on ne trouve pas donc vous voyez vous
avez toute une série d'actes alors je
voudrais qu'on termine rapidement un
diagnostic avant de regarder les
propositions pour voir si ça correspond
à des réponses adaptées maintenant
qu'est-ce que vous mettriez comme mot
sur cette crise de l'hôpital en fait ça
contre des projets dans la volt ou vide
c'est 2019 enfin un terreau urgences
puis un terreau hôpitaux on peut ne pas
être d'accord avec les propositions de
ses seins dit enfin de ces collectifs
mais en tout cas c'est c'est eh bien ce
moment là c'était bien avant le col vide
moi je trouve pas qu'il ya une perte de
sens pendant le coc vide au contraire
contraire on a eu des gens qui étaient
des syndiqués enfin des gens qui râlent
est pourtant aujourd'hui je parle moment
mais qui au moment du coc vide se sont
pas du tout dit ah bah non les autres
gens restent chez eux n'ont au contraire
il était là il râlait sûrs de leur école
moyens manquent de masques ou non m mais
l'hôpital n'attire plus l'hôpital
nageurs de lutte mais pour des raisons
simples c'est qu'on nous raconte plein
de choses sur on est autour du patient
tout ça en fait les personnels n'ont pas
d'avenir à l'hôpital on les traite très
mal enfin quand je viens quand je vais
dans une entreprise privée ou
graines dans une entreprise publique je
vais dans des locaux qui sont propres
entretenu l'hôpital c'est dégueulasse
notamment les vestiaires notamment
toutes les parties que les patients
voient pas et je parle même pas des
chambres de patients sains temps
saint-antoine par exemple quand mes
parents ont été hospitalisés il ya un an
et demi il y avait il y avait des
punaises de lit quoi c'est pas normal
c'est dans un état lamentable des plus
grands hôpitaux parisiens et donc on a
envie d'en on travaille dans de très
mauvaises conditions l'organisation en
fait professeur guidel à 10 mai
l'organisation chacun a sa propre
organisation
l epa congruente les uns avec les autres
et effectivement au moment de la crise
on n'avait qu'un objectif mais on avait
un seul type de patients aux siens c'est
ça simplifier beaucoup les choses et
puis on parle de l'administration mais
moi je suis donc je suis médecin
gouvernance de l'hôpital non mais là
c'est pas la gouvernance chacun sa
propre gouvernance alors on a on
empilait les niveaux de gouvernance il y
avait un vrai service les chefferies de
services moi je suis chef de personnes
ont fait dans mon service parce que tout
est en silo les infirmières dépend de la
directrice des soins infirmiers qui est
très du chameau sur ce sujet
on est on est dans une organisation qui
est folle et puis on a mis au dessus
l'épaule alors on a créé plein de
couches de chef mais en fait au niveau
c'est quand même le service le niveau de
base on y revient d'ailleurs et puis et
puis personne à la main sur
l'organisation et chacun fait ce qu'il
veut bah ça marche pas bien
effectivement moi je connais plein de
confrères qui sont partis ailleurs alors
évidemment moins pour des raisons
pécuniaires mais aussi parce que un
chirurgien quand il au bloc a eu tort il
opère à 8 heures
cette crise au fond elle va bien au delà
au delà le ras-le-bol bien au-delà dû
revenir oui alors dans ce set morosité
ambiante
je voudrais quand même apporter une
touche positive vous savez il ya
beaucoup de gens qui en vieillissant
s'interroge à leur vie professionnelle
en disons pas dû servir nous on a
entièrement d'accord se pose pas cette
question là je veux dire on a une
responsabilité majeure pour les wii
vient sans bien sûr mal à ça on a donc
servi
absolument ce qui fait que je pense
qu'il faut arriver à inverser la
tendance parce que si on continue à dire
c'est l'enfer c'est terrible les femmes
avortent en france mais vous aviez un
millier d'étudiants en formation
infirmier qui ont démissionné oui
non mais ils ne veulent plus y aller
ouvrir je vais à l'essentiel et ce par
les infirmiers les aides soignants dans
le service il faut comme si on veut
inverser cette tendance
il faut quand même dire et rappeler qu'
on a une fonction sociale fondamentale
vie est vide de malades on parle de
patience
le les balades bon et on a on a
une responsabilité vis-à-vis d'eux est
un échange est d'une richesse
extraordinaire donc je pense que si on
arrivait effectivement on va en parler
remettre l'hôpital dont le dans le bon
ordre
on est extrêmement attractif alors on en
parle que de ce fait je vous redonne la
parole juste après on va regarder ce que
proposent les candidats à la
présidentielle ce qui est sûr c'est que
tout le monde en parle les promesses
pleuvent en direction des soignants tous
les candidats proposent des moyens pour
former plus recruter plus et mieux
rémunérer les soignants revue de détail
avec alex clio regarder
l'hôpital a besoin d'un plan d'urgence
la pression qu'on les soigne en compte
les femmes et les hommes qui font de
l'humain ça suppose de continuer à
embaucher davantage oui ça coûte de
l'argent mais le rôle du politique c'est
de réorienter vers les vraies priorités
l'hôpital public qui aujourd'hui fait
seul face à la crise pour sauver
l'hôpital tous les candidats sont
unanimes il y a urgence à créer des
postes de soignants mais dans quelle
proportion les besoins et les moyens ne
sont pas les mêmes pour tous d'ici à
2027 eric zemmour voudrait embaucher 40
mille soignants valérie pécresse 25000
tout comme anne hidalgo plus à gauche
les ambitions sont encore plus hot 100
mille soignants recruté à entendre jean
luc mélenchon yannick jadot ou encore
fabien roussel quant à philippe poutou
ils promettent 200000 créations de
postes mais pour embaucher faut-il
encore former ses personnels marine le
pen promet d'ouvrir dix mille places
dans les centres de formation des
infirmiers et aides soignants anne
hidalgo met l'accent sur les médecins
elle veut en forme et 15 mille nouveaux
chaque année eric zemmour parle lui de
doubler le nombre de professionnels
formés dans les écoles et en médecine
quand la france insoumise s'engage à
former les 100000 soignants qu'elle
souhaite recruter et pour rendre les
métiers d'infirmiers et
d'aides-soignants plus attractifs les
verts promettent une augmentation des
salaires de 10% c'est 12% pour eric
zemmour
marine le pen elle voudrait débloquer
une enveloppe de 2 milliards d'euros sur
cinq ans nicolas dupont aignan propose
de son côté de créer une prime
spécifique pour prendre en compte la
pénibilité de ces postes
j'en au caire va se jouer on le disait
voilà tout le monde veut plus de
soignants recruter plus d'effectifs
mieux formés mieux payés c'est déjà ça
non alors oui qu'ça d'vrai pour aucune
des choses que nous avons dit ici chez
vous ce soir c'est à dire que en fait le
sujet central à mon avis c'est laisser
les hôpitaux s'organiser comme ils
l'entendent or mathias chago a expliqué
ces espèces d'empilement de structures
de dyarchie que césar moi j'avais dit
exactement 30 ans claude evin qui est
émise a sorti et je les coutures
réformer l'hôpital tu écris une ligne et
demie chaque hôpital est maître de sa
structure celle ci est définie par
salamanque dans la gouvernance les
autonomies de la gouvernance et et que
par ailleurs il ya c'était pour ça que
je voulais intervenait ce que me disent
mes amis médecins c'est qu'il ya
déclassement progressif des tâches c'est
à dire que ce que font parce que je
connais bien les systèmes de santé
étrangers tous les systèmes de gestion
aux états unis en ordinaire c'est
d'aider le médecin à faire de la
médecine c'est pas de faire de
l'organisation
mais c'est de laisser alors qu'est ce
que ça veut dire concrètement par
exemple c'est l'endroit dolly bell de
fermer des lits nos jours à thouars sur
la fermeture des dites ferme de libre il
n'y a pas de personnes ne paient pas de
personnel donc ça ces seigneurs de
symptômes de tous les politiques on
ferme des lits parce qu'il ya pas de
personnel la jouer un grand hôpital
parisien où d'autres
séries en moins mollo gino a fermé de
70% celi très mouillé un médecin qui dit
qui autrefois pouvait dicter des
observations et avait pour les del
accompagné des secrétaires etc mais
qu'aujourd'hui on fait l'hypothèse qui
va saisir lui-même sur ordinateur
l'ensemble des données vous avez un
déclassement des tâches bertrand guidet
s'il y avait une ou deux mesures a
soufflé au futur président élu kerry
quel sort est elle est ce que c'est
c'est une crise de management aussi que
vous traversez ses revenus question de
moyens elles fonctionnent nos
fondamentaux
de l'hôpital on est là pour s'occuper
des malades et on n'a de cesse de nous
opposer des indicateurs
des quais voisin possède indicateurs
d'identification des accréditations des
malades et des batteries d'indicateurs
vous savez moi je parle de l'indicateur
pastèque c'est lundi caster il est vert
dehors mais en fait il des rouges à
l'intérieur je veux dire ce qui compte
c'est ce qui a du sens pour le malade
donc il faut revoir complètement
les logiques ces indicateurs ce sont des
chiffres au snow la rentabilité
tarification d'activité c'est-à-dire
ceux les éléments qui concourent à
financer l'hôpital ce sont des éléments
uniquement quantitatif tout ce qui est
humain appelant pas valorisées et donc
tout le temps que vous parlez tout temps
qu'une infirmière a
parlé non non non non on en a parlé avec
à mettre de l'humain de glen soins ce
n'est pas valorisé ce qui valorise et
c'est l'acte technique de la même
manière que sur les espaces traduit
concrètement de valoriser l'humain mais
honnête moment avec de l'argent avec
quoi d'un vieillard pour elle
vous avez une chose le ratio
soignant-soigné aujourd'hui en france
une infirmière et une aide-soignante je
vous donne l'exemple d'une infirmière
elle a entre 12 et 15 patients dans un
service c'est vraiment le minimum je
vais dire aux états unis par exemple au
canada ces six à huit patients il ya des
études qui sont sorties plus on a deux
passions plus on est on risque de faire
une faute et plus il ya un risque de
mortalité déjà ça ça permettrait à voir
deux soignants de travailler dans des
conditions dignes prendre le temps pour
les patients parce que les soirées le
nombre de malades par la médicaliser
aussi des gouvernances moi je pense
qu'il est important aussi le médecin
reprennent le pouvoir les médecins mais
aussi les infirmiers qu'ils aient du
poids dans les décisions de l'hôpital
parce que les directeurs d'hôpitaux en
majorité sort de l'école de rennes donc
c'est ils ont une mort mais voilà ils
ont une formation management mais ils ne
connaissent rien au soudan ont pas mal
de doutes sinon ce n'est pas ma nature
oui l'homme à ressorts humaine on va
dire oui voilà et pas du tout dans le
soin donc c'est les soignants qui
connaissent le soin qui sont là près des
patients alors dites-nous par exemple
paris le problème ça va faire on va
m'accuser encore de plein de choses mais
en fait il ya moins d'infirmières il ya
plus d'infirmières par lit parce qu'il
ya moins de glee oui on a fermé des lits
pas un nom dans les pays étrangers on
est un des pays qui a laissé le plus de
lits ouverts donc parce que c'est j'ai
regardé on est
et d'hôpitaux donc yahia concède
hôpitaux et on est très démago et puis
on s'entre tout sur l'hôpital tous faire
l'hôpital il ya aussi la médecine de
ville et c'est important aussi qui est
des interactions passe quand vous le
voyez vous aux urgences quand les
patients sortent en postopératoire le
suivi c'est pas trop ça et souvent ils
reviennent parce qu'ils ont eu des
complications parce que le suivi par les
médecins de ville à l'horizon
des classements mais à l'étranger ce
dont beaucoup de nos confrères s'y
oppose mais on a aussi vous parliez de
comment on évolue quand on est une
infirmière environs qui ont des firmes
hier et puis après on est cadre ce qui
épate toujours
l'envi de tout le monde en plus les
cadres sont pas bien payés et mais par
contre il ya les infirmières pratiques
avancées donc ça commence enfants et
nous une bonne et nouveau enfin les
médecins c'est qu'andy l'évolution de
carrière le cocktail de la kippa notre
organe le plus novateur s'y sont opposés
clairement en écrivant une lettre au
ministre de la santé donc on voit bien
que c'est des pistes mais que parmi vos
pistes je l'assommé à bertrand guidet
sortir de l'hospital au centrisme c'est
à dire qu aux urgences heures moto mais
max dragon explique très clairement et
d'ailleurs ils osent poser des questions
à un peu qui fâche c'est on accueille
trop aux urgences très clairement on ne
peut pas soigner les gens qui ne peuvent
pas anticiper un remboursement de 25
euros d' acte médical qu'on peut faire
chez un médecin en ville il ya plusieurs
choses ça pose le problème du maillage
territorial et il ya effectivement quand
même des déserts médicaux avec des zones
vraiment on s'est compliqué où là le
seul recours c'est d'aller à l'hôpital
parce qu'il n'y a pas de médecin tout
simplement il ya le problème de l'accès
au plateau technique avoir la biologie
de l'imagerie mais c'est vrai que les
médecins souvent c'est pas très facile
donc sa pause de près de maison de santé
avec deux voix encore de voilà donc cet
emplâtre assez sur ses 13 ans et en
termes d'attractivité pour les médecins
n'est plus dans le médecin généraliste
qui va faire ses visites à domicile et
qui va faire 20 km pour aider paul de
ces
gens peuvent s'organiser avoir des
plannings une j'ai eu une vie familiale
féminisation de la profession qui fait
que ces mêmes les mêmes les mais même
les mêmes gens qui
veulent moins travaillé que l'on ne plus
longue reconnaître la pénibilité au
travail de finir avec les horaires
décalés sans ces maisons de saint gobain
en finir avec des horaires décalés sur
ces intrusions
c'est tout mais il faut comprendre qu'on
les fait naître ailleurs la poule
horaires annoncés juste pas en plus
c'est à la place des autres horaires
alors fait pas de r&d tombés d'accord ce
décade pour dire que 1 des problèmes de
l'hôpital et c'est ce que vous disiez
c'est l'organisation de la médecine de
ville et donc c'est un autre et que
notamment on va vivre le vieillissement
des générations du baby-boom et l'entrée
de la grande dépendance et c'est
vraiment urgent de revoir la médecine de
ville pour éviter des hospitalisations
et ce que vous disiez c'est pour le
suivi des patients quand ils reviennent
à domicile et c'est vrai qu'avec un
médecin payé à l'acte 25 euros on n'y
arrive pas intéressante avec l'aco vide
on n'a fait que mal alors qu'est ce que
vous allez le bris le suivi à domicile
des patients même être traitée ce pas
oxygène de mission tout à fait il ya
maintenant des systèmes qu'on appelle
prado d'accompagnement de deux malades
en sortie après chirurgie après certains
certains
la télémédecine alors après le problème
de la télémédecine c'est assez adapté
pour le suivi pour une première
consultation mais il faut il ya l'humain
et puis il touche et quand même touché
le patio cas examinés pour les rejoue
ses propositions parce que vous faut
qu'on dessine un peu votre diagnostic
même si vous n'avez pas nous dire quel
est le candidat qui est le meilleur
diagnostic logements sociaux de
proximité de l'hôpital pour tous les
soignants
stabilité des horaires
una moratoire sur les fermetures de lits
tout ça c'est ça vous parle dans le
concret on est un petit peu c'est pas la
priorité pour les soignants je pense la
priorité pour les soignants c'est tous
les jours c'est quand ils prennent leur
garde à 7 heures ou à 20 heures et c'est
le nombre de patients c est ce qui est
un médecin sur place parce
qu'aujourd'hui
parle beaucoup des ehpad aujourd'hui
dans les ehpad ya pas d'infirmières la
nuit c'est quand même fou on a un livre
qui a fait un boom etc mais aujourd'hui
vous visité plusieurs ehpad dans la
région parisienne ou en france vous avez
pas d'affirmer vous avez une
aide-soignante et une auxiliaire de vie
reprendra ses opérations au fond cette
remise à plat cette
première dix ans pour former un médecin
cinq ans pour enfin deux ans maintenant
pour les gens de pratiquer avant son
l'hôpital retrouvera de l'oxygène non je
mets un solution que le diagnostic soit
vraiment ou si vous voulez 1,3 en défaut
moi j'ai regardé de près les les 12
et j'ai fait une petite chronique dans
le point sur ce sujet
malheureusement il y en a aucun à mon
avis qui a vraiment grâce à mes yeux
parce que les sujets centraux qui sont
la liberté d'organisation l'hôpital est
le deuxième sujet qui est le suivi des
malades en ville autrement que par des
médecins payés à l'acte nul n'a pas
l'importance qu'il faudra retenir pour
conclure professeur guide et rien ne se
fera sans tous les acteurs c'est ça il
faut vraiment tenir compte pour comme
vous dites prendre en compte l'humain
que tous les acteurs de santé visuelle
par la
wii et donc les modalités de financement
parce que des pousses on s'adapte donc
effectivement quand on impose à
l'hôpital un certain mode de financement
va il s'adapte donc on a vu ça depuis
dix ans c'est à dire qu'on était
rémunéré à l'acte dont vous êtes plus en
plus d'actes et chaque acte était moins
bien rémunérés ce qu'on appelle la
régulation prix volumes ce qui fait qu
au final l'activité a augmenté de 30 %
et des effectifs n'ont pas suivi et donc
les les personnes se sont retrouvés
complètement surchargé donc réfléchir à
la modalité de financement de l'hôpital
ça ça aura un impact sur le
fonctionnement de l'hôpital et fidéliser
les papilles soit la nasa faire revenir
les 180 milles soignants qui ont changé
de métier qui ont pour beaucoup envie de
revenir et qui oui il y en a beaucoup
qui ont envie de revenir mais on a
raison les ponctions trouver les moyens
pour les attirer à nouveau merci
beaucoup merci pour avoir partagé voilà
ce diagnostic sur ce sujet central et
qui est devenue prioritaire aux yeux aux
yeux des français vous rester avec moi
mathias wargon on va parler un petit peu
de vous
présent car vous vous raconter aussi
dans votre livre vos origines vos choix
de faire médecine à défaut d'être
comédien ou humanitaire vous avez aussi
le tweet rageur marié une membre du
gouvernement vous avez poussé quelques
coups de gueule on verra tout cela à la
fois sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire mais pas seulement votre
portrait en quelques questions avec
marco pommier regarder
si on vous invite mathias wargon c'est
parce que vous êtes l'une des figures
médiatiques de la crise sanitaire un bon
client comme anti le coguic 19 et sa
gestion on l'a presque oublié mais
c'était l'un des sujets fétiches des
candidats à la présidentielle juste
avant la guerre en ukraine on a tué un
pays sans pour autant vaincre le virus
oui on en fait trop et on en fait trop
depuis le début non ce qui est frappant
c'est le caractère absolument incohérent
de ce qui est décidé nos décisions se
sont toujours fondée sur la connaissance
scientifique
mathias wargon vous êtes médecin chef
des urgences de l'hôpital delafontaine à
saint-denis dans un livre vous livrer
vos solutions pour réformer l'hôpital un
chef-d'oeuvre en péril à vos yeux
pendant cette crise sanitaire nous
retenons de vous vos critiques contre
les politiques démagogues face aux
restrictions masque confinement
couvre-feu tout y passe tout le monde en
prend pour son grade depuis le début de
l'épidémie on a affaire des politiques
mais tous bords 1 que si qu'ils soient
au gouvernement qui soit dans
l'opposition enfin tout ça qui font de
la démagogie en permanence permanence
qui s'appuie sur les études idiote on
prend les français pour des cons pour
deco langage cash fleury vous assumez
votre côté grande gueule depuis deux ans
vous enfiler les gants de boxe pour
monter sur le ring médiatique dans votre
viseur didier rahout et ses admirateurs
les antilles vax sans oublier ce que
vous appelez les épidémiologistes deux
plateaux où les rassure east eux vous
rice fortement le poil nous avons une
maladie un peu dangereuse mais quand on
confond la dangerosité avec le manque de
soin mais ne d'ailleurs fait soit par
moments d'un a marre il n'y a pas de
soin les gens qui meurent quand vous le
25 mai à sion ces 25 une personne n'y a
pas de soins adaptés soignons mais j'ai
réussi tous les jours est ce qu'un
personnel considère les jours soit les
conneries alors monsieur l'urgentiste
votre côté grande gueule vous at il
plutôt servi ou desservies dans la vie
surtout quand on est marié à une femme
ministre et à l'heure où le co vie 19
joue les prolongations
près de 130 mille cas par jour en
moyenne par qu'avez vous appris
personnellement de cette épidémie
quelles sont les erreurs qu'il ne
faudrait pas répéter quelque chose me
dit que vos réponses seront franche et
directe
c'est vrai ça ce côté impulsif d'où
est-ce qu'il vous vient ce franc-parler
ce côté grande gueule j'ai été mal
élevés
j'en sais rien c'est ma nature je suis
comme ça j'ai toujours été comme ça des
choses sur un an mais j'ai tout votre
enfance vos parents non mais met pas en
valeur travail et donc j'ai quand même
été il veut un peu seul puis enfin seul
le chien frère mais non mais si c'est ma
façon d'être en fait il ya un moment
j'aime bien dire les choses par contre
oui j'ai pas été élevée dans une famille
on disait voilà il faut faire attention
à ce qu'on dit faut le dire de façon
correcte parce que c'est pas des milieux
où enfin ces millions d'ha ses frangins
justement vous avez été élevé dans un
milieu populaire vos parents n'ont pas
fait d'études et on sent que c'est très
important pour vous dans le livre que ce
soit bien clair là dessus qu'on vous
prenne pas je cite pour un de ces
bourgeois éloignés du peuple où l'on est
médecin de père en fils pourquoi c'est
si important à la fois c'est ça mais à
la fois c'est les trente glorieuses donc
moi je déteste les discours
misérabiliste des gens fin quand on
écoute tous les médecins ont
l'impression de tout leur mère était
femme de ménage donc moi c'était des
commères donc c'est vrai moi c'était des
commerçants et la période du plein
emploi et du plein emploi on avait un
pavillon en banlieue à clichy sous bois
mais quand même un beau pavillon avec un
jardin j'allais au lycée enfin c'était
pas cessé pas aulas quoi c'est juste que
c'est les milieux qui existaient à
l'époque où on allait arrêter l'école
tant que c'est des gens qui ont vécu la
guerre et qui après guerre on arrêté
l'école à 14 ans et on bosse à quoi la
seine-saint-denis d'ailleurs vous y avez
vécu enfant et vous y être retourné
après pour quelles raisons vous avez
décidé d'y retourner parce que c'est pas
comme je venais de la fontaine c'est
difficile à l'hôpital la première fois
que j'y suis retourné c'était en 2001 et
s'était pas de la fontaine c'est à
bobigny c'est un peu le hasard j'avais
fait médecine j'ai fait des urgences
j'étais parti un peu dans l'industrie
chant venu un peu par hasard à bobigny
la deuxième fois que j'y suis retourné
c'était il ya quatre ans comme chef de
service j'étais déjà chef de service
dans un autre établissement et là oui
c'est une vraie un engagement c'est un
vraiment en fin d'engagement
parce que je suis un petit peu
prétentieux je pense que je sais diriger
un service d'urgence et je pense que ce
sont des gens que moi donc avec de
l'expérience
qui doivent aller dans des endroits
comme ça c'est à dire des endroits un
peu plus difficile qu'ailleurs à la fois
parce que parce que c'est compliqué
d'être en seine-saint-denis a un peu
d'actes militants aussi nommé
sensationnalisme non mais c'est du
professionnalisme cezelly longtemps de
dire qu'il faut que ça soit des gens
allez on va le dire des jambons des gens
bien formés qui doivent aller en seine
saint denis ou dans d'autres endroits
comme ça quoi oui c'est dans des
endroits difficiles on doit être nous
quoi et paraître en vue d'amener et vous
dites dans votre livre parce que vous
rendez vous parler maintenant en faire
bien sûr non mais c'est intéressant
parce que vous avez appris à lire à la
librairie de votre père la libre et
mathias qui porte le nom votre nom votre
prénom c'était bon vivre d'ailleurs vous
lui dédier un peu vous voulez à tout
prix professeur oui voulez mais parce
que c'est pareil pour lui c'est un peu
ça c'est un truc que j'ai appris dans
l'épidémie en fait le fait d'être
professeur vous donne une parole plus
importante que si vous êtes docteur même
si vous n'y connaissez rien
dans l'esprit des journalistes et dans
l'esprit de la de la population tout à
fait hélas le professeur guidère il se
sert pas de son titre de professeur
faire déjà un lien d'intérêt je le
connais personnellement c était mon
directeur de thèse de sciences donc on
se connaît autant le dire mais voilà
c'est pas ça assez vous pouvez
d'ailleurs on vous donne du professeur
même si vous l'êtes pas parce que c'est
important est bon pour mon père c'était
important pour lui réussir sa carrière
de médecin à l'hôpital c'était devenir
professeur donc temps que j'étais pas
professeur j'avais pas tout à fait
réussi et tous les professeurs invités
sur les plateaux pendant l'épidémie
alors ça ça vous à quoi énerver non à
gacé non on a été beaucoup invités on a
tous profiter de l'épidémie faut le dire
moi je trouve ça très marrant d'être
invitée sur les plateaux j'en profite et
donc il y en a compris ça un peu au
sérieux en fait il y en a qui se voyait
déjà en haut de la fiche ministre de la
santé directeur général ne savent pas
quoi en même temps c'était sérieux cette
parole était très fort on avait besoin
de repères ouais mais il y en a qui sont
enfin il y en a ils sont perdus oui je
pense qui en accueille six ont perdu
d'un seul coup c'est pas une question
non en fait il ya des gens qui d'un seul
coup se sont vus en fait c'est c'est
grisant d'être invités moi j'étais
invité avant avant l'épidémie alors vous
allez signer une tribune mais avant
comme et opéré au début au début avant
au début j'étais invité l'été et l'hiver
pour dire que les urgences étaient
pleines ce a pas beaucoup changé et donc
j'étais invité et j'étais sincèrement je
faisais dix minutes j'avais l'impression
qu'on mettait là et voilà moi j'avais
j'avais quelque chose à dire puis a eu
l'homéopathie et je suis devenu un bon
client et j'ai été reçue un peu
différemment c'est à dire plus seulement
comme le médecin lambda mais avec un peu
plus d'égards fait mais c'est vachement
mais un chouette marolles non mais je
suis super content aussi et la vie des
croyants athées au cid et là où c'est le
cas puisque j'ai écrit un bouquin sur
hôpital de dire ce que je pense et
d'affirmer valeur parce que les valeurs
c'est vachement important on a parlé d'
engagement tout à l'heure mais on est
aussi dans une société où finalement
même nous médecins on a continué
médecins infirmiers on a dit oui on
n'est pas des bonnes soeurs la vocation
c'est pas vrai en france en fait on
s'aperçoit que c'est vrai et qui a une
recherche de sens dans ce qu'on veut
faire donc être invité à la télé être
intéressés démentent pas assez par
passer de l'autre côté c'est vachement
grisant vous allez aussi d'ouvrir votre
gueule pas qu'à la télé ou votre
carrière oui dans ma carrière oui parce
que je suis pas facilement malléable
parce que je supporte pas d'avoir un
patron enfin voilà quoi iad autorités
n'ont jarretelles et est l'autorité
c'est pour ça que je suis le chef c'est
pour pas avoir deux chefs ont fait alors
dites moi un tout petit peu par rapport
à ceux ce chapitre que vous avez
intitulé ma femme ministre il fallait
mettre les points sur les i non vous
n'avez pas plus de moyens parce qu
emmanuelle wargon est au gouvernement
vous n'avez pas plus de réseau plus
accès au ministre de la santé nourris
mais j'ai 55 ans j'ai mon propre réseau
chez un professionnel des urgences j'ai
été membre du conseil d'administration
de la société savante
voilà j'ai mon propre réseau ces jeux
fonctionnent aux confins ligne de crête
quand même nom s'attendent ya toujours
un côté l'une de crète mais j'ai pas
d'accès particulier à olivier ferrand si
c'est la question si une fois il m'a
engueulé en direct par twitter interposé
voilà mon accès parce qu'on n'était pas
d'accord sur un truc quoi et voilà trois
heures du matin s'est un peu engueulé
mais rien de grave sur un mais voilà
j'ai pas d'accès olivier vers ans j'ai
pas d'accès à des politiques en
particulier je vais pas des soirées
mondaines voilà j'ai ma vie normale là
vous êtes le plus virulent alors vous
avez pensé bloquer votre constructeur un
moment quand emmanuelle wargon a été
nommé et puis vous voit pas trop d'état
d'âme finalement vous êtes revenu et
vous taper très fort contre les anti
vaccins et en particulier contre didier
rahout le professeur house seulement
compris sur la question c'est la
suivante est ce que vous trouvez que les
médias et les politiques ont pris trop
de temps avant de comprendre ce qui se
passait autour d'eux
il ya eu un aveuglement ouais hein il
est professeur et ça et il continue à
jouer là-dessus le cv didier raoul sas a
impressionné tout le monde et c'est pas
comme ça qu'on fait et les journalistes
sont des littéraires et ils n'ont pas
d'idée je m'en suis aperçu à ce moment
là en fait c'est la parole du professeur
qui compte est comme un match de foot il
est champion de france il est champion
du monde et des médecins aussi qu'ils se
sont engagés derrière didier rahout oui
oui tout à fait et politique non mais
quelques pas beaucoup de professeurs et
des gens et des gens qu'est qui était
déjà problématique et puis il ya comment
on fait la science la science quand vous
lisez un article scientifique vous
regardez pas qu'il écrit vous regardez
l'article et comment il est fait et dès
le début pour le problème s'est posé sur
les articles de didier rahout moi je
n'avais jamais entendu parler de ce type
avant et puis avec toute sa structure de
l'ia chu qui pour le coup sur twitter a
été assez virulente le problème c'est
pas didier rahout le problème c'est la
place qu'on lui a donné avec des
articles qui était mauvais c'est pas lui
le problème il est ce qu'il est c'est
pas la question moi on me ramène
toujours a dit raul parce que c'est plus
simple moi je m'en fous didier raoult
est en fait moi la problématique c'est
qu'est ce qu'on fait de l'hydroxyte leur
quine quand on est des articles dont
c'est dès le deuxième chapitre taper la
méthodologie que de toute façon qu'ils
trouvent que ça marche ou ça marche pas
on sera on n'en saura pas plus
c'est ça la problématique et puis c'est
aussi faire le buzz à la télé parce que
ça marche comme ça ap les chaînes d'info
marche comme ça est opposé les médecins
et je le dis souvent il ya 95% des
médecins qui étaient d'accord sur 95%
des choses et on a voulu montrer les 5%
où il n'était pas d'accord hôpital un
chef-d'oeuvre en péril c'est avec la
collaboration de jean marie godard c'est
votre premier ouvrage vous avez compris
c'est une contribution pour résoudre la
crise de l'hôpital principalement mais
c'est aussi très intéressant de vous
découvrir vous matière wargon parce que
vous dites jeu dans ce livre rester avec
moi on va terminer l'émission avec la
page présidentielle de cette émission à
j - 12 avant le choix des français pour
le premier tour ça s'appelle le ficam
vous connaissez désormais
[Musique]
mais avant l'été il y a les deux bras de
fatalité au grand remplacement et bien
molle vous proposent leurs housses de
mort d'agir pour le climat
l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la prendre
orange ma chronique
travailleuses et travailleurs le système
vous exclus il ya un vrai problème de
pouvoir d'achat rendre à la france sa
grandeur à réussir c'est à prague
l'histoire c'est le vol
deux chroniqueurs dans le scam ce soir
stéphane blakowski bien sûr pour cette
journée rien bague bonsoir à vous et
céline bracq
qui va nous dévoiler le baromètre du
mois de mars baromètre lcp public sénat
sur la présidentielle on commence avec
votre oeil l'oeil de blacko attiré par
qui par quoi aujourd'hui le matin myriam
comme d'habitude je feuilleter les
journaux et je me suis rendu compte
marcheuse surprenant c'est que la presse
ne s'intéresse quasiment plus à la
présidentielle alors qu'on est à quinze
jours du premier tour oui ce n'est pas
le seul à avoir un petit manque
d'intérêt pour la campagne regardez
aujourd'hui en france et libération
n'est pas un mot sur la campagne pour
les 1,5 au but pour les autres c'est la
gifle de will smith même les journaux de
référence comme le monde ou le figaro il
en coûterait peut regarder sur la
présidentielle en en gros si un peu pour
qu'on voie les articles c'est l'essence
d'un côté et l'ukraine dans l'autre et
la présidentielle on s'en fout un peu
alors pourquoi ça manque d'intérêt déjà
il ya le truc quand une élection connaît
le résultat est en tout cas convaincu de
connaître le résultat serait que ça perd
un peu d'intérêt
et puis y avait un truc à changer cette
semaine de sears ça concerne donc pas la
presse écrite mais la radio et la
télévision et à la stricte égalité de
temps de parole entre tous les candidats
ce faire qu'il ya des candidats que les
journalistes n'avaient jamais envie
d'inviter n'avais pas envie de les
inviter au qui pensaient que c'était pas
intéressant et là ils sont obligés
exemple dupont aignan la semaine
dernière il a été invité dans une q2
matinale de radio aucune de télé non
plus et là ils n'ont pas eu le choix les
journalistes et donc ils ont reçu de
montagne ont à la fois sur rtl et sur
inter ce matin c'est rtl bon voilà
qu'est ce que ça a donné et on pensait
qu'il serait content d'avoir enfin voilà
ça permet trois millions et demi
d'habitants d'auditeurs le matin et pas
du tout en fait vous savez qu'il est un
peu anti système donc dupont aignan donc
c'est toujours un plaisir de se disputer
avec les journalistes pour bien montrer
qu'il mange pas de ce pain-là dont ce
matin quand il a dit qu'il trouvait
élections étaient truquées oh la la
qu'est-ce qu'il avait pâti de ce que
alba ventura n'était pas d'accord on
n'écoute
rien scrutin était truqué de harrah's
aide par des médias complaisants de
monsieur macro est une oligarchie que
vous représentez je vous dit réalisme ce
que vous faites je dis ce que je vaux
pas mieux ce que vous représentez une
casse s'est du coup vous oublierez au
lieu des français voilà on a larcher qui
contestent la légitimité et pécresse qui
parle du vol de l'élection là il nous
dit qu'elle est truqué donc les mauvais
perdants effectivement s'accumulent
c'est un petit peu inquiétant peut-être
pour le salut au climat de l'après
deuxième tour quoi alors avec cette
égalité stricte on les appelle les psys
candidats présents que jamais exactement
à lui renoué jeudi poutou donc ce matin
noté gâteau était sur bfm et i arrêté
sur rtl dont elle parle à plus de cinq
millions de personnes en deux jours pour
un candidat qui n'a jamais dépassé 1% à
la présidentielle c'est assez inespéré
d'avoir un tel auditoire donc comme en a
donné 15 secondes à denis nicolas dupont
aignan au nom de la stricte égalité
égalité devant deux parents on va donner
aussi 15 secondes nathalie arthaud qui
va nous expliquer pourquoi il faut
mettre à bas le capitalisme on les
écoute aujourd'hui la plupart des
grandes multinationales c'est vrai pour
l'énergie c'est vrai pour l'alimentaire
c'est vrai pour la santé aussi ne
fonctionne pas pour être service de la
population pour répondre à leurs besoins
c'est à dire que les les profits passe
avant la vie humaine et c'est vrai pour
tous voilà à trop cher la vie n'a pas de
prix
cette chanson de notre jeune avec
l'idéologie là au moins et pour tout ça
donne quoi ben pour tous c'est un peu le
même programme mais vous savez que ça
arrive des programmes qui se ressemblent
regard des macros et petre pécresse
presque le même programme aussi donc on
pourrait se poser la question est ce que
ça vous ramon le coup d'avoir deux
candidats trotskistes à la
présidentielle et je pense que c'est
surtout le jean luc mélenchon qui
doivent se poser la question parce que
souvenez vous du résultat 2010 est quand
on additionnait les voix de jean-luc
mélenchon à celle de couteau et artaud
voyons on a fait l'addition on obtenait
un score qui est supérieur à celui de
marine le pen donc en additionnant les
voix de footwear tôt il aurait été au
second tour comme là il est sur le point
d'arriver au second tour on se disait
alors les deux petits candidats vous
voulez que la gauche veut
la réponse de philippe poutou bout
d'abord ça peut être un peu décevant
pour ceux qui croyaient à l'union de la
gauche dire que ça n'a aucun intérêt
pour lui d'un de permettre à mélenchon
arrive au second tour puisque toute
façon il est convaincu que ce sera ma
con qui sera élu donc 15 secondes pour
philippe poutou
mélenchon il peut très bien peut-être
pourquoi pas atteindre le second tour ça
c'est qu'on va pas l'exclure parce qu'on
voit que dans les sondages finalement 1
quatre points d'écart pourquoi pas mais
le deuxième tour il est annoncé perdant
dans tous les cas de figure d'un point
de vue mathématique du point de vue du
rapport de force électoral de manière
lucide aujourd'hui la gauche ne peut pas
gagner les élections voilà donc c'est
donc le représentant de la gauche qui
dit que c'est impossible lui il veut que
ça se règle dans la rue voyez c'est
quand même sympa qui s'intéresse aux
petits candidats et en même temps par
rapport à la préoccupation qu'on avait
au départ savoir si il n'y a pas un
manque d'intérêt pour la campagne je
sais pas si ça permet vraiment de ce
côté de près cette campagne ou pas oui
j'essaye de m'intéresser mais vous son
contrat politique et moi je me suis
toujours intéressé à la politique c'est
intéressant la politique disons qu'en ce
moment c'est sorti on a les partis
extrémistes qui racontent ce qu'ils
veulent puis après les autres on les
entend quasiment pas quoi alors on va
parler avec vous ces lignes de l'effet
mélenchon mais d'abord on révèle le
baromètre de mars je rappelle que vous
êtes la directrice générale de
l'institut de sondage oddo que ça on
commence avec le président candidat dont
la cote de popularité progresse
nettement
54% des français considèrent que c'est
un bon président on appelle ça céline
l'effet drapeau oui parce que l'effet
drapeau parce qu'évidemment en cas de
crise en général les français se rangent
derrière le chef et en particulier quand
il ya une crise internationale quand il
ya une guerre c'est vrai qu'il ya ça
alors ils étaient déjà des scores très
haut rang quand même en intentions de
vote et en popularité c'était pas mal
mais il ya vraiment eu un boost au
moment de cette de cette crise
ukrainienne de la gamme alors ça fait
c'est doublement favorable d'abord parce
que ça le met en situation très
favorable par rapport à ses
prédécesseurs ces dix points de plus que
nicolas sarkozy à la même époque un peu
plus du double par rapport à françois
hollande et puis il s'est assez
consensuel en tout cas auprès des
sympathisants des partis traditionnels
qui se range pas mal derrière lui on a à
peu près la moitié des sympathisants
d'europe écologie les verts qui disent
qu'ils ont une bonne opinion de lui on a
40 % de sympathisants socialistes
beaucoup plus de sympathisants à l'air
ce qui est un peu inquiétant pour
valérie pécresse évidemment et et ça
signifie que finalement est certes il a
un petit peu reculer dans les intentions
de vote la campagne s'est un peu polaris
et d'intentions de vote il mon père
il atteint 2,3 points 15 jours
honnêtement il est encore très très haut
mais en fait les deux les deux les deux
qui ont bougé ce sont les deux qui sont
deux candidats et justement les extrêmes
marine le pen d'un côté et jean luc
mélenchon de l'autre qui aujourd'hui
autour des 14 % d'intérêts présent
jean-luc mélenchon va s'y attarder dans
ce baromètre forte dynamique également
pour l'insomnie sa popularité atteint
des niveaux qu'il n'avait pas connue
depuis 2010 est avec 33% de bonnes
opinions est ce que ça veut dire que ça
peut se transformer en vote alors aussi
ce qu'on va voir avec petit cours de
sondage un potentiel de vote alors un
potentiel de vote c'est pas une
intention de vote c'est une question qui
mesure le la part de gens qui
envisageraient de pour en voter pour un
candidat donc on leur dit est ce que
vous pourriez voter certainement ou
probablement pour un candidat et pour
jean luc mélenchon ce potentiel se situe
à 27 % c'est-à-dire qu'on à 12% de
français qui disent pouvoir voter
certainement pour lui et 15 %
probablement c'est beaucoup généralement
la part des certainement ça ressemble
aux intentions de vote un ou deux points
près et 15% c'est vraiment la cible du
candidat ce qui peut aller chercher et
bonne nouvelle pour lui c'est une cible
sérieuse que c'est parfois il ya des
candidats qui suscitent un peu de
sympathie mais deux camps de gens qui
vous trouvent en fait jamais vraiment
pour lui là c'est vraiment à gauche
qu'il a ce potentiel dans des cibles
intéressantes pour lui c'est à dire des
catégories populaires plutôt des jeunes
maintenant par rapport à sa principale
concurrente pour le second tour marine
le pen ce potentiel de vote il est
diplômé en dessous donc il ya encore du
travail pour les prix la salle alors
qu'est ce qui pourrait pousser les
électeurs à voter mélenchon voilà on a
posé des questions de raisons du vote et
ce sont des explications qui sont aussi
de nature à relativiser finalement cet
effet mélenchon parce qu'on a seulement
42 % de français qui seraient
susceptibles de voter mélenchon parce
qu'il soit qu'ils adhèrent à ces
propositions c'est les 32% soit parce
qu'ils disent il aime beaucoup le disent
qu'ils pensent qu'il al'étoffe d'un
président 10% donc 32 +10 a fait 42 % et
vous voyez qu'on a
25% pour permettre à la gauche de peser
voilà en réalité c'est aussi
nul parce que je ne vois pas tout
voilà on a une majorité de gens qu'ils
font par défaut parce qu'ils pensent que
c'est le candidat qui est le moins
éloignées de leur valeur ou
simplement par vote utile donc vous
voyez voilà c'est à dire qu'on voit dans
tous nos sondages que les électeurs de
gauche se sentent un peu orphelin et
qu'ils se disent bon il va falloir un
moment qu'on vote si on veut aller voter
et mélenchon ça peut être ce candidat
mais ça crée pas un élan
les choses les on demande aux gens ce
qu'ils sont sûrs de la beauté ce que tu
es moins sûrs d'aller voter c'était
jadot hidalgo et le troisième de gauche
qui est sensé de pouvoir sera les dents
quand même possibilité que les gens
hésitent et se disent allez la gauche au
second tour l'épi ce sont aussi les
sympathisants de gauche qui se disent le
plus on n'y va pas en fait
entre entre les électeurs de mélenchon
et des électeurs de marine le pen ce
qu'il ya des vases communicants oui il
ya des vases communicants mais plus dans
l'autre sens c'est à dire que quand on a
à peu près deux fois plus d'électeurs de
mélenchon qui se disent qu'ils
pourraient aller voter pour marine le
pen que des lecteurs
pourraient voter pour mélenchon
effectivement moment mélenchon j'ai vu
passer un sondage mais il était très
anciens sur les électeurs de mélenchon
qui pouvait voter le pen j'ai pas vu de
trucs récent mais
si vous regardez dans le sondage on a
mis les là je vous livre pas tous les
détails mais sur notre site internet sur
votre site internet je pense qu on a
tous là les appels point fr des votes
qui pourraient se poser sur l'image de
la de mélanger encore fermés c'est le
dernier point j'allais j'allais oublier
ça et c'est aussi ça aussi qui bloque le
plus jean luc mélenchon on disait ça a
progressé certes mais si 33% des gens
ont une bonne image ça veut dire les
deux tiers ont une mauvaise image sur le
baromètre qu'on fait régulièrement avec
vous il fait toujours partie des
personnalités les plus rejetée et quand
on teste ses défauts et bien les gens
nous disent oui il est impulsif il est
agressif il est populiste il est même
secteur pour une bonne partie des gens
alors c'est un peu mieux qu'avant c'est
à dire qu'il s'est quand même adouci il
ya du progrès mais c'est pas de nature
non plus être se former complètement
l'image d'un mélenchon qui fait encore
un peu peur et là on a vu les défauts
mais les gens lui prépa non source et on
reste là baromètre aux docks ça c'est
d'une brac merci beaucoup c'était très
clair merci stéphane je rappelle le
titre de votre livre matière wargon
hôpital un chef-d'oeuvre en péril c'est
aux éditions fayard merci à vous très
belle soirée sur lcp et à demain
[Musique]